we're living in an era of unprecedented
threats coming from directions no one
could have anticipated Jill Stein you
too saw now Russian agent here's a new
one we told you about last night
racist trees in Palm Springs California
city officials are planning to clear-cut
a grove of tamarisk trees because
they're racist locals say they were
planted more than 50 years ago to
separate a golf course from an
african-american neighborhood last night
we spoke to a local resident about their
sinister presence there's part of the
conversation if you've done any research
on the tree you'll know that's one of
the nastiest trees around and it's also
been declared an environmental disaster
by the federal government
now now what because that tree is a
foreign tree you're calling it nasty yes
question is could Palm Springs be
overreacting at all to the racist trees
in its midst aptly named Forrest
Richardson is a golf course architect
he's consulted on the course in question
actually Ethan Berman is a radio show
host and they join us tonight first to
you Ethan you've been following this
you're from California clearly this is
the definition of structural racism but
I wonder if it couldn't be worse I mean
these are Tamara's trees if they were
white pine trees would they be more
racist do you think no the trees
themselves aren't racist it was the
actions putting them there in the first
place but also I think it's really
important to note these trees in
particular have been a fire hazard this
year you look at you know we Fox has
done a great job covering like the
Thomas fire tamra's trees themselves
have been explosive during these fires
that have been happening so not only do
we have the aspect of the traditional
the origin of the planting of these
trees being to separate the black and
people of color community across the
street after their homes were demolished
by the way by the city of Palm Springs
under racist conditions this is one of
those times let's set the record
straight let's clear out these that are
fire hazard let's not waste the water
and let's set let's so everybody wins
the trees are not just bigoted but
they're flammable forests here's my
concern if we take down the racist trees
could the homes
be hit by racist golf balls well I don't
know I would like to think that
nothing's racist especially I would too
but my eyes are open now you know the
the reality is that I don't know why
these trees were planted I don't think
that there's any clear indication of why
they were planted one reason that we
plant trees on golf courses especially
on narrow corridors which this happens
to be this is about 240 feet in width
whereas today we would we would
generally get 350 to almost 400 is to
protect adjacent homes and property
whether it be a school or houses and in
my opinion you know I think though the
win-win would be to get everyone on
board and say what's good for the
homeowners and what's good for the golf
course it was good for the other but
it's 2007 so we don't you compromise I
mean come on now it's the modern era but
let me just ask you is there just to
clarify as a landscape guy are there
other reasons other than simply bigotry
that they might have been planted you
know I I did as much research as I could
when I worked briefly on a study for
this golf course we got a lot of
historical data and and I was able to
find what we think is an early 1960s
image that actually shows that this
hedge of Tamra's trees was probably
there before many of the houses were
built not all of them but the the hedge
was probably predated many of the homes
being done there so obviously that
doesn't mean they're not racist trees I
mean his you know he's sometimes is not
obvious if a tree is racist or not but
let me even let me let me just get and I
sort of by your point that they're both
bigoted and a fire hazard but I wonder
if this isn't a teaching moment right at
a time we could all learn instead of
cutting them down maybe we could make
them better trees somehow prune them is
that not a possibility
no let's just let's get them out of
there let's get back to some native
trees that we have [ __ ] what do you mean
Nate you know for a guy who's in
California I'm serious palm trees are
not native eucalyptus are not native
should you expel everything from Calem
native okay so you are you a nativist
now when it comes to vegetation
absolutely eucalyptus trees have become
a real problem with tipping over in the
store when you're calling other cycles
bigoted alright they weren't originally
from California therefore we have to
kill them but we but but come on Tucker
we have a severe water problem in
California we have a lack of leadership
in Sacramento we have a lack of
leadership in DC when it comes to the
water issue in California and we're
we're diverting water to water trees no
I layer here but for it but for so let
me just finally close out I mean is it
possible that if we cut these down you
don't always know what you've got till
it's gone I mean if you were to pave it
and put in a parking lot do you think
you might regret that well the trees are
serving a purpose I can tell you that
now if they could maybe be replaced by
better trees yeah you know I think I
think your guest last night mentioned
eucalyptus so it's interesting your
guest tonight is saying no eucalyptus
and that because there I got to go but
they're foreign trees we're against
foreigners now forest Easton thank you
for that you thinking thank you good to
be with Christmas thank you thank you
very Christmas